quoi ces maisons oui quoi il renvoie
relance élise moi ça me dérange pas je
viens de produire si tu veux pour 8,8
ont trouvé là bas ben quoi mais il n'est
pas bête écoute enfin je veux dire s'il
a envie ttt m toi peut-être deux écoles
et beaucoup à jouer sérieusement pour
vous pourrez toujours tourné là-bas il
ya une grande chambre
je sais pas comme ça tu curieux de
savoir voilà de revoir les lieux de voir
comment ils ont évolué comment comment
le temps les arts modifié malmenés
valait même pas enfantin je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse la visiter notre je suis
passé devant que j'avais un truc à faire
dans le quartier elle totalement
abandonnée tu peux te retrouver dans
cette poule de chiasse pouvoir quand le
ton à malmener modifié visiter t'as pas
un plan plus à la voile je peux boire
les faire en famille comme ça tous
ensemble à antoine
mais je ne dis pas ça pour d'insultés
oui mais de toute évidence un ami j'ai
pas plus de 20 ans à se barrer de la bae
et toi tu veux retourner là-bas pour
vérifier si le vent a bien déposé les
feuilles mortes sur la toiture rouillé
en cette magnifique calcul on s'en
branle un compas le programme la ls
lantoine écoute
il a juste envie d'aller se promener moi
je peux accompagner ses patrons non
c'était mauvais si évidemment moi j'ai
envie d'aller à auschwitz pour aller me
branler don de sang séché pour écrire un
poème en tête ça suffit mauvais goût ou
mauvais goût bon allez alors louis père
raconte raconte moi une histoire les
potards